hi there steve kaufman here and today
i'm going to talk about pronunciation
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notification
and for those of you who listen on apple
podcast
please feel free to leave a review we
greatly appreciate it
so pronunciation the reason i want to
talk about pronunciation
is actually two things that happened
today first of all i had we had house
guests my wife and i
these are very good friends we knew them
from japan
uh he was a consul general in osaka
he was a language student of japanese
way back when i knew him in the early
70s
he married a japanese girl and so
you know we've seen them from time to
time over the last 50 years
and they live in kelowna they came by on
their way to whistler and they
overnighted with us and we have of
course we just
talked forever went for walks and uh we
were talking about wine
and he referred and he speaks french and
he said
uh sauvignon blanc sauvignon
i've heard people say sauvignon blanc he
didn't at least he didn't say blanc
and i thought to myself he knows i mean
we have the sound in english it's not
saving it so
we have the word we have that o sound in
english
blanc but because in english we're
a bit sloppy in how we pronounce things
no i'm sure
but i know he's a sticker like i think
even in speaking french he would say
so there's a certain lack of attention
to
the sounds you hear this all the time
and i think i'm going to give examples
in other languages where
our english habits if we're english
speakers tend to dominate
our efforts to speak the foreign
language
uh now the other thing that was brought
to my attention this is
i think it was a person's name was maybe
mike murphy
commenting here uh on my uh one of my
youtube videos about noticing that
and he's been teaching in china for a
long time and
even with all kinds of work with the
international phonetic
alphabet ipa which i find quite
unhelpful but people don't notice
certain things
and so he noticed though that a lot of
chinese people and he said can't
pronounce the word
usually they say you're li and and
absolutely i've heard so many chinese
people say yearly
so i'm thinking about those two things
so
in english we're a bit lazy with our
vowels so the vowels we don't say
we don't clearly say so being
and that's how english is you know we
just kind of slur the vowels a little
bit we don't give the vowels the full
value
but there are languages where they do
like french
or spanish or japanese a full vowel
in russian and in portuguese some of the
vowels
kind of fall away but in in many
languages
they want the full value for the vowel
that's not to say that
that they don't also slur so in french
you know we want to have the clear you
know set that deal
but people then end up saying study so
that they don't give it full value in
you know instead of saying
so all of these things happen but we
have to start by being able to notice
the clear clean correct pronunciation
and we have to be able to do it and only
once we have that
correct pronunciation and the ability to
hear it
and to reproduce that clear
proper sound for that vowel in that
language
only then can we afford to get sloppy
so and going back to the chinese example
of course
if you've ever been to beijing and taken
a taxi you can i mean even
as someone who speaks chinese it's hard
to follow them because it's
it's a ror it's a very rr type of
if they're from beijing uh and so maybe
that's what carries over them
into the english instead of going
usually
you know if you really thought if that
chinese speaker
would sort of look at it and of course
the problem in english is that the words
aren't written the way they're
pronounced
so it's not je there's not a a soft
j sound like in french you know where
you would have a j which has a
sound usually has that same sound but
it's written
s u u ali and of course
in most words su doesn't have that uh
you know value we say supreme
supreme suffer uh
english stuff in english and stuff but i
i
i think that chinese speaker and there's
so many of them who say you're really
they have to sit down and look at that
word and practice saying that word
correctly and then eventually they'll be
able to
incorporate that word into a sentence
that they speak
you know at normal speech and i remember
that you know now i've learned lots of
languages but french and [ __ ]
and chinese were my first and i actually
worked hard at the pronunciation
i remember this the chinese sound like
chuefa
is to lack we don't have that in english
so i had to work at it and i would
pronounce chinese and i particularly
remember
trillian trillian and to the point where
the muscles here in my
in my jaw were kind of sore
i also remember trying very hard to
improve my
french pronunciation because even though
we say like pronounciation
you really if you're an english speaker
you have to work hard to
force yourself to say pono because the
tendency
from english which which is what our
brain is set up for
is to say pronunciation it does not
pronounce yes you know it's
pono and it's it takes an extra bit of
effort
to give it that full value
and once you have the full value you can
then
you can you can kind of slur over it a
bit but if you don't have that
essential you know that core ability to
make those sounds correctly
then you're going to end up with the
equivalent of urali that the chinese use
for
usually and this is true in all
languages
i mean spanish also has pure vowels and
they're not diphthongs so it's not bueno
an english speaker will say bueno no
bueno or whatever it's
bueno bueno we have to focus in on that
and i don't think the
uh international phonetic alphabet helps
i think you have to
listen very carefully and then repeat
very deliberately
and uh you know in in a way if you do
the mini stories at link you get
sentence by sentence and you can hear
the natural
uh you know voice read those sentences
so you can
you can listen to the sound text to
speech for one word but you can also
hear a sentence
and then try to imitate it and when you
try to imitate it
really work the jaw muscles so that
you're giving it the
full value if in the case of
if it's chinese that it's true for the
real church is coming in
if it's french it's um if it's uh you
know
bueno bueno cut that it's not a bueno
it's
and and we have to hear those things we
have to develop the ability to
hear the difference between how we sound
and how the native speaker sounds
and focusing on some of these key sounds
so you build up a base
the ability to make these sounds and
it's difficult it's difficult at first
you might make it once
but then within a sentence you'll lose
it i'll always remember in montreal
i used to hitchhike to mcgill university
because
you know it was a long bus ride and
there was another fellow hitchhiking and
he was an immigrant from southern italy
and we got friendly in fact we ended up
looking for work on construction sites
in montreal together
and his english was terrible and i was
trying to help him
and uh so he couldn't say small he would
always say
jamal jamal and
it was quite frustrating no no small
okay so i say go small
and he went small for whatever reason
he was pre-programmed to sage mall maybe
he heard it from other
people from southern italy i don't know
i don't know
in the end i went we worked construction
for a couple of months and then i went
down to the dock and i was able to
hitchhike on a boat going across to
europe so i worked in a boat going
across europe i
haven't seen him since i don't know if
he still says jamal
sounds like the e in french and in other
languages where they have an
u sound that takes a lot of work and
you know the traditional sort of
suggestion is to go
put your mouth in sort of the shape to
go and then just try and say
ee so if you go
you'll end up with an u even if you're
able to produce the u
to get to the point where you can
produce it on the fly
in a phrase or a sentence it takes a lot
of practice
so you got to notice it you got to
practice it individually and then you
want to get into
doing it in sentences so my suggestion
on pronunciation is begin by
really focusing and so if you're a
chinese speaker and you say you're
really
get a hold of that word look at it break
it down
say you just usually
usually usually usually get to where you
can say the word
and then usually i like to go you know
usually
when i study languages i do this that or
the other so throw it into a sentence
now the second suggestion is
to pronounce well there's two things we
have to do we got to hear it we got to
be able to produce the sound we don't
have to get 100
but more or less the second thing is
we don't want to resist that sound so
you know there are and we don't want to
resist anything that has to do with that
language
so you know swedish now
and if you are feel self-conscious about
doing that
then you won't do it so you've got to
not feel self-conscious
and in that regard i find that if you
can get a hold of
in that regard are many stories in lake
aren't great because they're kind of
narrated without feeling right i enjoyed
when i was learning mandarin i enjoyed
the
the xiangxiang dialogues because there
was a lot of feeling in those these are
comedians telling a story
and i think the same when we learn
languages sometimes if we can get a hold
of something that's spoken with feeling
that we connect at an emotional level
and
sometimes we can have fun with it in
different languages you know we can say
you know just sort of get into them
that you get into sort of almost like a
situation where emotion is involved
and so you play at the language and and
so that way you're connecting you're
creating some emotional connection to
the phraseology and the pronunciation so
i think all of those things
are important it begins by getting a
grasp on how it's actually pronounced
uh you know making the effort to
pronounce correctly which is
more effort it's an effort to say
pronounciation
you gotta work at it until eventually it
becomes natural
and then get a hold of
something that you can emotionally
connect to and then
imitate when people speak with some
emotion
in most situations you won't be you know
kind of wrapped up in that and but it
again it helps and and i think for
people who haven't learned as many
languages as i have
uh i have to admit that the first few
languages i worked hard
on pronunciation and then i think that
introduces a level of flexibility
in the brain so that subsequent
languages first of all there's a greater
likelihood that there will be sounds in
there that we have already
noticed and been able to produce
we're more confident we're less
self-conscious
and so things become easier but the
first few languages
i think one has to make a special effort
to get you know a certain minimum level
of pronunciation doesn't have to be
perfect
but yeah when i hear sauvignon blanc if
the person is trying to speak french
to me that's just not good enough anyway
there you have it
enjoy your sauvignon blanc bye for now